I'm sick you can't just let go knives
knives boards oh just look okay
seriously just let go any worth it
why do you choose to explode well it
wouldn't be better but I mean it'd be oh
there goes my balls I don't feel like I
won double course well there you go
I didn't know I was supposed to avoid
that okay take two oh I'm gonna make it
this time already lost an arm good sign
there broham oh that happened damn
beautiful but wrong one more time I can
beat this one I know again
take that Santa well I didn't kill you
but I bet you're gonna die soon anyway
who did it with my feet that's not what
she thought oh this I got it with my
legs it's gonna kill you dead killed me
[Applause]
finally surprised at the beginning of
all these levels okay cut is what kid D
what we need to do is we didn't get over
there because now the guide was the
world when you made a lot easier because
all the harpoons or nuns will get your
fat ass flat wall
come with us with us weird brother Roger
don't kill them
I can't didn't brace the sweet grip of
this bastard
[Music]
grab the harpoon wait hi God grab the
harpoon I got it yes what am I doing
with it now
oh I'm killing myself barely whoa don't
kill self don't kill self uh kill self
don't kill self don't kill stuff don't
kill self at least in my ass he can't
kill me if it's in my ass possible hmm
this one was made for Toby all go by now
take that impossible level can you
please stop arrowing me please
thank you for rants Rob fling back yet
una blue flare - first I wear a little a
bulky oh I gave up I apologize to all
the French viewers out there I am of
horribly if fans grab the coin gonna
grab the coins here did you just grab it
[Music]
hunted part one wait for the screen it's
all important nope not gonna drive away
don't you know that there's a bunch of
bad stuff happened I don't even know I I
didn't wait for the screen film I don't
hello baby
how you doing we're gonna have
[Music]
dipping a jump now I've showed my own
header box Oh Ryder meaning that we're
riding through hell Oh Oh that smarted
just a little bit okay let's go okay
let's wait okay now let's go go go go go
this one is diabolical
okay let's just go come on kitty we can
go I can make it oh no oh no get out
here oh yeah oh no no no no no no no no
there we go now we can make it walk bro
remember the rate going off the
destroyer finally this has been happy
wheels highlights thanks for watching if
you liked the video and want to see more
why not subscribe today wanna help the
channel grow leave a light and then to
your favorites will share with your
friends on Facebook and Twitter thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
why that long helical I never be okay it
was killed King I'm good
well that happened you're the king baby
[Music]
nope damn